my manager who's my brother
my older brother
and my lawyer is my other older brother
and
that's been helpful because
no matter like it's weird it gets weird
with everyone no matter what one of the
best advice i was given was by uh
charlie sheen you got advice from
charlie yeah we were playing uh the wise
sage of our generation yeah why
say harley queen but it was it was
really wise i was sitting next to him
and we were we were
playing some late night television and
he said this was right at the beginning
he just said boys
just mark my words your life is about to
get really weird that's all i said but
it stuck with me forever is charlie
sheen's of course sticks with you
and i remember being like right okay
charlie you know i'm not charlie sheen
it's not gonna get weird like you know
um
but it got really really weird really
quick because suddenly
you've existed your whole life in this
way where everybody just
everything you get
you achieved it was because you got it
and and every conversation you had like
if someone liked you at the end of that
conversation was because they liked you
if they didn't like you is because they
didn't like you
and you could make complete peace with
that at least i could my whole life i
was like life is a challenge
and be myself and i want to go through
it and find some people along the way
that i connect with and others know and
that social
integrity
is so important to us
and we think it would be nice to have
this and this is going back to the the
pitfalls of fame we think it would be
nice to walk into a room and have
everyone be like
yeah and you could be like
dumpster fire and everybody's like oh my
gosh dumpster fire is amazing
you said dumpster fire was amazing
it's like
it's incredibly
incredibly lonely and it just breaks
everything that you knew about
humanness yeah and it sucks so then
you're seeking out
people who
that it doesn't exist with and families
the closest you can get to that for sure
but even your family it's going to take
a little bit where they're like oh this
is a little weird like all my friends at
work are now asking about you and you're
my young stupid brother but now you're
suddenly like the young stupid brother
they want an autograph from and stuff
and it still makes like they have to get
over that and figure that out and
and um
and then you meet people too who know
about this whole concept and they're
like well i'm gonna be an [ __ ] to him
to show him that i don't
subscribe yes
and you're dealing with like people who
are like dumpster fire the person who's
like
you know you could say something
actually profound and nice and they'd be
like that's stupid and you're an idiot
yeah
because it's like an actual attempt to
like show you how much they don't care
so you live in this very like
this still nevertheless even when nobody
knew you you were seeking for deep
human connection with a small number of
people
and now when a lot of people know you
you're still looking for deep connection
with a small number of people
the struggle is the same yeah
you